الرئيس الاوكراني زار مناطق في خرسون عادت
الى اوكرانيا زياره لرؤيه عمليات اعاده
البناء في المنطقه بين خرسون
اكد للسكان ان عمليات البناء ستبدا بسرعه
خاصه عند سؤاله عن عوده الكهرباء الى
المنطقه كما طمانهم ان النصر قريب مهمتنا
الاساسيه هي الكهرباء نحن نفهم ذلك كما تم
اعلامي عن مشاكل المياه الان يتم امتداد
المياه عده مرات في الاسبوع اعتقد اننا
سنعيد بناء كل شيء انها الزياره الثالثه
للمناطق التي عادت الى اوكرانيا خلال
يومين زار قبلها خاركيف ومناطق اخرى زياره
الى خرسون بينما تشتد المعارك في بخميس
اوكرانيا اعلنت انها تعتزم الاستفاده من
ارهاق القوات الروسيه هناك كي تبدا هجوما
قريبا جدا حسب تعبير زيلينس كي باخم تعيش
المعركه الاطول منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا والجيش الاوكراني ما زال صامدا
فيها معركه صعبه لكن يمكننا الدفاع عن
باخموت ما يلزمنا هو امتلاك اسلحه يمكنها
صدو الهجوم اعلنت سلوفاكيا عن ارسال اربع
طائرات ميج الى اوكرانيا فيما حذر
زيلينسكي زعماء دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من
ان التاخر في تزويده بطائرات حربيه
وصواريخ بعيده المدى قد يطيل امد الحرب